lil nasdaq's just gave birth to his
debut album montero what can we expect
with this baby you're delivering on the
17th this baby is going to be a world
changer the 22 year old musician shared
the news of his new baby with a wild
video on instagram thursday giving birth
to the album
um can we just take a second to
acknowledge lil na's ex's acting skills
like someone hand him the oscar and a
grammy duh yes oh my god i'm so thankful
okay now back to the video i'm gonna
need you to focus on your breathing
and just follow our lead
okay you ready ready he's ready the
montero call me by your name singer
eventually pushes out the montero album
cover which he then cradles lovingly in
his arms
thank you huh it's sorry to grab me
nominated
on thursday the day prior to the album's
drop lilna's ex teased that the baby was
on the way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after he said he was quote having
contractions
[Music]
he also shared several clips from his
baby shower but sadly no one showed up
[Music]
but he did get presents from all of his
famous friends like megan knee stallion
doji cat miley cyrus elton john who he's
been collaborating with a lot recently
you look amazing oh you look amazing
thank you thank you and jack harlow
who's on his track industry baby of
course the superstar singers are all
featured on lil nos x's new album all
the collaborations you've done lately
elton john miley cyrus megan
cyrus megan what do you say to these
people i'm just like please please and
thank you hop on this song and it
happens it's been a big week for the 22
year old artist it's gonna be a week
it's gonna be a great week who attended
his first ever met gala on monday
sporting three gold looks by versace on
the red carpet are you still feeling are
you on i feel amazing
and the night before that the georgia
native had heads turning in this lilac
versace pantsuit with a matching train
at the mtv video music awards
you are serving up some fashion tonight
yeah stop it
lil nas x took home the vma for video of
the year the top honor of the night for
montero call me by your name
[Music]
e.t was backstage with lil nas x after
the big win you are just feeling
next level right now i'm feeling like
i'm on cloud like 179
000 million i'm so thankful i'm so
thankful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you